the
foreign office released this statement
we have information that indicates the
russian government is looking to install
a pro-russian leader in kiev as it
considers whether to invade and occupy
ukraine do you believe that i do believe
that it's not the first time they're
trying to do so historically and even in
recent times and by the way all the
names you mentioned and
these people actually were helped from
ukraine to russia and they now reside in
russia by russian special services
do you actually have any evidence or do
you think that foreign office has actual
evidence of this
these people including former prime
minister mr azarov is appearing from
time to time on russian state tv talking
about the what could be achieved if he
is back in in service and even the
president yanukovych is in russia and
rastavan don so all these people are
handy at hand if they need it and that's
what russia is doing by the way they are
fighting in the courts and even london
courts for three billion euros which
they these people received from russia
in exchange not to sign the european
association agreement so all of the
things if you combine
you will seem much much but much bigger
picture you mentioned mr azarev one of
the other individuals mr muraf has said
this morning
that this claim is i'm quoting here
stupidity and nonsense he denies it
points out that he is banned from russia
so he's hardly likely to be a russian
agent
mr murad is active ukraine politician
yes with russian views but we allow this
discussion to go on in ukraine this guy
is just quite openly appears on tv he
has his own tv channel and he won't he
tells whatever he wants but i believe
that he's young politician he's also
building up his reno and that's what
he's trying to do you know appealing to
the forces in ukraine society who still
believe that soviet union and russia is
the best way for ukrainians to to
develop
do you um
and the ukrainian government
genuinely think that mr putin will
invade the ukraine we don't just think
that he would he as you mentioned
rightly and not many people by the way
remember that he is already there he is
already in ukraine for all this almost
eight years so there is not yeah there
is not big news for us the issue is how
much he would bring up with
is it fully scale invasion or it is as
was mentioned discussed many many times
smaller things just you know to annoy us
and the rest of the world to show his
strengths and believe that we will back
back down is ukraine uh prepared to
fight militarily very unfortunately we
are prepared to fight we are gathering
the forces we have times more than
russians are now keeping into our border
but again we are not that well equipped
to for the prolonged fight with russians
the um
the british i think have sent you some
weapons and some trainers um we
understand that the that germany has
decided not to do the same and indeed
has blocked uh
another country from doing so what are
your feelings about germany today
this camera is around not allowing me to
tell what i think of germany and now
right now if i have somebody from nato
to say something it's just you and me
tell us
you know if if i have somebody from nato
to tell things like that i would expect
germany to be the last ones so many
ukrainians i still remember what germans
did in our part of the globe and ukraine
especially we were talking 80 90 years
ago we are talking about both of the
words worlds world wars and both of them
were now a part of the globe and our
lands were occupied and there is no
ukrainian family which was not touched
by these wars
that is quite a
major accusation to throw at the current
german government that it is repeating
the treatment of ukrainians
from
the last century that's what knows not
what i said what i said is that if i
have to listen from somebody about
things like ukraine is not to be given
the weapons to defend itself the germans
would would have to stay at the very end
of the of this long long line of our
european partners
okay you are not going to rely on
germany because you think they will will
never really come to your aid we rely on
them in economic sanctions if they are
serious with that but i don't see the
seriousness when they are still keeping
laying down the pipelines going around
our territory so would you like them for
example to um
cancel nordstream oh absolutely that's
what we ask them so many times our
pipelines allows as many as much of the
guests to come as they want even more so
there is no particular need and we
understand that each and every nation in
the in nato in europe can do their part
german have
has to play some significant role if
they're not ready to provide us weapons
defensive weapons okay they might do
something else which will help us
i'm sure that will be heard in berlin in
washington um the
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
has been holding talked with his russian
counterpart sergey
lavrov um
what what are the ukrainian government's
red lines what does it
say to the americans you must never give
way on in these negotiations it's very
good issue because we've been talking
about this supposedly happening big deal
between russian and russians and
americans and what we were always saying
to to our american colleagues that if a
promise too much as a compromise please
be coordinating with us because some
things we won't be able to do just for
our own future something like that like
we will still go to nato and european
union this is for nato and you to decide
whether we are becoming a part of the
family but that's what we wanted to do
and that's why we actually suffered all
these years not because we're different
we've been living with russians for for
centuries that's because we decided to
take another model of our development
which is european
western democratic whatever the words we
will use to describe it so to for
clarity
is the ukraine's current position that
it would like to join the eu
and also at some stage nato absolutely
that's what we made clear eight years
ago and that's russia with that's why
russians came and it didn't change our
resolve even in ninj
so a clear signal to washington that
whatever you do whatever you agree do
not
agree to the russian demand that
the ukraine should not be allowed to
join nato yeah please leave it outside
outside the conversation the rockets the
forces in europe there are some things
which americans can discuss and that's
in their own power because most of these
troops are american but something which
will ukraine will suffer please
coordinate it with us first
the underlying point here is does the
west have the stomach for the fight
what is the view in ukraine at the
moment the earlier in the week president
biden said the united states might
tolerate a minor incursion in ukraine
and he's [ __ ] retracted the phrase
since then but do you
essentially believe
that when it comes to
the final decision
vladimir putin
uh
and against the west that the west
has the
stomach you know to face down putin
i believe it's getting there if you look
at all these years seven plus years when
we start asking people to help us with
some military equipment to defend
ourselves we couldn't even start this
negotiation after seven years we already
have seen the doors opened uk united
states some other nations are coming
openly to send us weapons which not
important only as a military step but
this is political step the political
stance they are showing russians you
know what we understood it after all
these years you killed so many of the
ukrainians thirteen and a half thousand
it's not minor incursion anymore this is
war if you can step down please do it
that's the still chance for that
we um here are a long way away from this
and you know to some extent uh if i'm
honest and i may be guilty of it this
morning we
uh treat mr putin as a sort of
fascinating character and
joke a bit about him but
what what do ukrainians really feel
about this if
the diplomatic channels fail
and that there is
an invasion
um
what will the ukraine do we have nowhere
to to go i mean we corner it in our own
biggest land in europe but still that's
enough
for us and we are not inviting them to
all we will fight to death unfortunately
so many people of our nation will
probably die but we will try to get to
that world as many russians as they come
the picture that you paint what do you
think
the scale of that conflict could be how
serious could it be i i believe i still
hope that this is just threats as of now
russians might change their mind
especially putin who knows whether he's
had he might want to you know regain the
soviet union by the way it's
100th anniversary of formal formation of
soviet union this year he might come to
this particular day to love it very much
but i believe that west will with each
and every step west will you know
stiffen the spine and we'll come to to
our seasons but we're not relying to it
much we are preparing ourselves